hey everyone and welcome to another HD
tutorial in this video I will be showing
you how to upgrade your current version
of iTunes whether you're on a Mac or a
PC to iTunes 8 the Plus version with DRM
3 music etc you've probably heard of it
right now just for this tutorial I'm
going to open up the internet browser
and navigate to apple.com it's not a
very complicated website here it is
Apple comm so what we're going to do is
go to the Downloads tab actually know
even closer go to the iPod plus iTunes
Apple calm and sorry about this we're
going to scroll down until we find
iTunes here's iTunes plus DRM free music
and iTunes Plus now from available from
all four major music labels so click on
learn more and it's going to give us a
download now link right up at the top
click on it and even if we have existing
iTunes even if we have existing songs
and videos and games in iTunes as well
as a paradigm iPhone or iPod you can
still download this and it will it will
actually sense during the installation
process oh you already have iTunes would
like to upgrade and it will send if you
click yes to the upgrade then it will
continue to save it will go on from
there to save all of your songs all of
your videos all of your music everything
that you have in your current version of
iTunes as well as podcast subscriptions
everything remain the same except it
will be DRM
so I would if you our you uncheck this
and I would leave this check just in
case a newer version or a discount shows
up now if you have 64-bit Windows Vista
you'll notice most likely if you have 4
gigabytes of RAM or more otherwise
you'll probably have regular 32-bit
windows XP or Vista when we're done
by the way this is available for Mac or
PC like I said hit the download button
so you most likely if you're watching
this video I already know what iTunes is
so I don't have to go over this but what
is new in iTunes well first of all the
genius toolbar is standard second of all
high quality DRM free music now what
this means is in previous versions of
iTunes you could only put your music
you purchased on what pod or on one
portable music device now if I were to
buy music in iTunes I could put it on my
lg Voyager I could put it on my iPod
Touch I could put it on someone else's
iPhone I could put it on as many gadgets
as I have maintained in my network there
are a part of my itunes works a bonjour
service right now so as you can see I've
opened up iTunes I've got any podcast
this is the new version of iTunes you'll
notice if I go into music to the right
is the genie sidebar which makes it
randomly will not randomly but it's
playlists based on recommended music
from the iTunes Store that you don't
have yet and it will tell you exactly
how to it'll give you direct links right
here where to get them you can hide the
cyber or even turn on genius but I don't
actually want to turn on genius always
yeah you have to sign in with your Apple
ID so I'm not gonna do that quite yet
but yeah there's a lot of good things in
iTunes 80 plus so I would highly
recommend you down this so even if you
already have a version of iTunes it will
automatically upgrade and save all your
files subscriptions to podcast and
everything so this has been another HD
tutorial thanks for watching go ahead
and subscribe if you have any other
tutorial ideas for me to do just go
ahead and send me a message thanks for
watching peace